really good comics and kind of slowly
there's a fly over the camera
like how big are the flies over there
your neck of the woods
[Music]
welcome back for another episode of
tacos
[Music]
we can add that in post right probably
not second season
less budget proven 19 in the building
it's your boy jesus strangle the host
with the most some people say the least
and this episode is a special one why
because we have
home state tacos and what else do we
have
fortune feamster this is tacos contodo
let's get it started
welcome to the show fortune feamster
what's up girl
what's up jesus good to see you buddy
it's great to see you thank you for
doing the show
i'm like really excited i remember the
first time i met you
i was parking cars at the comedy store
yeah and you were just the sweetest
and then i i don't know if you remember
this sometime later
um i was doing a college gig or
something and i ran into you i was at uh
i had a layover at the charlotte airport
yeah and i got my usual
uh bojangles a breakfast sandwich orange
juice and two extra
uh biscuits plain because yeah you know
you have to
and i was just scarfing them down i
remember looking up for you
and i saw you you were just giving me
that that awesome smile of yours and
you're like
hey i'm like i was just so excited to
see you
because uh i i'm from outside of
charlotte
and so i don't normally get to see uh
comic friends in that airport isn't it
the best though like when you run into
comedians at the airport i think there's
like no better feeling
you light up hey how's it going and we
are doing it by ourselves when we run
into each other it's such a treat
because you feel like
that camaraderie with each other i know
you toured with uh
bert this summer i ran into bert
kreicher at an airport he was in the
he was in the bar at like 8 a.m i was
like dude
that's him all right that checks out so
so down south they take biscuits very
seriously like what should people look
for in a biscuit uh first you have to
call it a
biscuit uh biscuit okay biscuits
uh they have to be fluffy
light but lots of butter so what are the
top three biscuit spots if i'm
if i'm in the south what are like real
deal uh biscuits
well bojangles 100 would be number one
django's okay
cracker barrel it's the popular place
down there
papa is is everywhere it's not just the
south it's a really good biscuit too
well awesome hey i just want to say
thank you for doing this and what do you
say
we dive in and we eat what do you yeah
of course
this is our version of how it's made
roll it
wow that was awesome what'd you think of
that oh that was
incredible i'm just messing with you
well i'm brianna also known as breezy
valdez resident home state in our on our
highland park patio
i'm on the mission to share the story of
texas through food
i was born in houston at my
grandmother's house she lived nearby
my dad's mom and we spent a lot of time
there most weekends we would drive to
her house out in the country
and she would always have
tortillas cooking she was always rolling
tortillas out when i opened homestay in
2013
i couldn't find a flour tortilla in la
and it was personally important to me
to share the flour tortilla with it with
the city that loved tortillas but
didn't really have a lot of love or
respect for the flour tortilla
we have what we call the breakfast taco
and that you can range from something
with eggs in it
something with beans in it and then you
can get into with the brisket
since the day we open the most popular
taco is the trinity taco
it's like kind of i think of it as the
americana taco it's
eggs bacon potato and cheese classic
i was a homesick texan for really
specific things i ordered queso and
at a mexican restaurant in santa monica
and i got
a cold like bowl of cold shredded cheese
i was like thank you
so yeah those like moments were like
okay this is missing like we gotta
we gotta fix this it's just basically
melted cheese which sounds really simple
but it's very hard to execute
melted cheese with a bunch of different
spices and herbs in it
you eat it with chips or you dip your
taco in it the frito pie for example was
something that
i grew up eating in the school cafeteria
and at school fairs and it
you know little league games and things
like that what authentic means is so
personal
and we all have our own story and so
we're not
a street taco we're not a burrito we are
literally something in the middle
oh look at this look at this bag full of
goodness
whoa i got look at this this is
salsa we got him oh this is amazing so
we definitely covered
homestay on a previous episode with bert
kreischer
oh yeah i love home state so much that
we had to
like i wanted to eat it for myself and
we had to like cover the whole thing
this is a trinity taco i don't know what
that means
it's uh spanish for delicious or
something i forget yeah brisket i love
brisket and then a whoa and then there's
a
frito pie wow a frito pie
you know bert ordered the same thing
and he said it spoke to his inner this
is like white trash pail that is
hilarious
it comes in a frito bag that's amazing
you could like walk around you could
walk around la
eat with this big old frito bag
the only thing they could do to make
this better is if it came with like a
little strap
have like a little side purse yeah ooh
these jalapenos are making me sweat
y'all
so how long have you been living in l.a
now 17 years
so 17 years do you feel like like like
you've developed like a spidey sense for
like
good mexican food out here now yeah it's
definitely evolved because
when i first moved here i kind of only
really knew like
nachos i hate like nachos and that was
it basically
my taste was like taco bell then once i
got to la
i really started to taste some more
authentic food
i studied in mexico uh for two summers
when i was in college
so i realized that uh
the food there was like completely
different because i was used to like
tex-mex
totally different but you know how to
speak spanish a little bit right
um poco hey that's better than me do you
ever go into like a
like like a mexican food spot out in l.a
with the
with the i took spanish in in in college
confidence like can i get two cats of
dealers perfect
no i'm too embarrassed i'm like hola
see you you speak it better than i do
do you have case over there too yeah i
got a big ass in your queso
this is the devil's nutella right here
look at this i'll put some
put some [ __ ] case on my uh holy
trinity oh man
hey if it's a holy trinity you've got to
baptize it yeah i mean well you are
jesus so you do yeah that's right you do
that
here we go moment of truth
oh wow get the people at homestead on
the line we got a new menu item you guys
so you're you're you're kind of like a
rare breed because
you know you're in the improv world and
you're in the stand-up world
yeah i started with improv i think it's
the best way to start
if you've never performed comedy before
to just go up on a stage
just you and a microphone for even if
it's three minutes it's terrifying
you're sweating bullets
with improv it's a real safe way to like
dip your toe all eyes aren't on you
and i sort of learned how to like dig
myself out of a hole
we here at uh tacos contodo we're such a
big fan of your work
and you're so funny congratulations on
your hour special super super hilarious
thank you you know i did some digging
and i found this
brenda character but what's crazy y'all
is that
tim made me think that he wasn't giving
me anything for mother's day
i woke up and he didn't say a word and i
was just like dad
ass oh b yeah she was like
how did the brenda character come about
long before i learned
how to do stand-up i was doing
characters i was filming something and
they had me dressed up
like a straight woman straight hair
a lot of turquoise purple blouse
and i just sort of channeled like all
these different women i grew up with
i started yelling at my husband tim
and since we have brenda here uh can i
ask brenda a couple questions
sure oh wait hey
hey jesus how's it going great how are
you brenda
oh i am so good i there's a bunch of
tacos in front of me
and i swear i feel like it's the last
supper
and i'm having a meal with jesus it's
that good if you could just turn my
lemonade into wine we'd be ready to
party you know what i'm talking about
let's do it
do you have any pet peeves brenda when
it comes to food
yes my pet peeve is when my good for
nothing
husband tim refuses to take me to my
favorite tex-mex
place and that's chili's when you and
tim
when it's when it's time to do the deed
what's
brenda's playlist i ha i have a tendency
to like
70s rock couple ballads from bon jovi
yeah some country music that's for tim
he likes that
but then i finish it out with a little
def leppard
some people like to cuddle death leopard
not me i like to get wild at the end i'm
like why
why stop now you know what i mean that's
a long playlist brenda
it sounds like you're a lucky gal tim
tim can go the distance for me i
like i make love to ringtones hey
you gotta do what you gotta do to keep
your man
[Music]
again i just wanna thank you so much for
your time you're so sweet
i love talking to you you're you're one
of the best
sending you a big socially distant hug
to you thank you
for your tacos contour this is the
second season thank you so much for
doing this and we'll see you next time
bye buddies adios adios
dear friends today was a great day
why you asked because i had homestay
tacos again
there's something very special about
those pillowy
tempurpedic flower tortillas that keep
you coming back for more
and more everything on that menu is
great
it's like a classic album you can go
right through it without skipping the
track
i was happy to break bread with my
friend from down south fortune feamster
we had some great laughs i even learned
a thing or two about biscuits
apparently there's a right way and there
is a wrong way to say the word
biscuits hopefully i said it right
your friend jesus trejo
tacos contour